I mean we all know how this story
started or do we hey folks
i-i-i just need to get this out of my
system a little bit so we are nearing
the end of series 12 of Doctor Who and
there's a lot in theory to be wrapped up
or brought back or touched on again or
explained or what have you to the point
that I'm actually starting to wonder how
much of it is going to get explained
this year and how much of its going to
get rolled over to series 13 but in any
case the big overhanging question right
now has to do with Joe Martin's
Ruth dr. um who I'm gonna refer to
because I don't know what else to call
her right now now I have done a little
bit of speculation on her and more
specifically I put together my arguments
and my ideas that what made the most
sense to me was that she came from some
sort of split timeline possibly as an
alternate alternative generation off of
eleven cuz I mean big massive you know
whole new regeneration cycle wonky stuff
happened that would have worked or
something else along those lines where
or you know it could have been you know
twelve holding back the regeneration
energy for so long there are you know
could have caused some sort of rifts
some sort of splitting some sort of
duplication however a lot of the
signifiers around this doctor seemed to
indicate somebody from earlier on the
interior style of the TARDIS the fact
that she doesn't seem to be readily
aware of the sonic screwdriver I
still don't leave that scene as her not
having a clue what it is but just being
more like but he need that for but there
is an argument to be said that maybe she
just doesn't even know what it is in the
first place both of which would indicate
somebody earlier on now in that case my
own personal favor is still the series
6b theory which I went to detail in the
other video so you can look at that
there however the big concern for a lot
of fans inand it was a possibility I
originally dismissed and I still I still
don't think it's going to be the case
but I really really really hope it isn't
as well but I'm gonna talk about it
because I feel like there's still a lot
of thoughts going on around this and I
also kind of want to put this on the
record either way because either this
will turn out to not be the case in
which case you know I'll have a little
record of that remember that time where
I swear I was silly and worried about
something that didn't happen or it will
end up being the case and I'll have my
initial thoughts on the record ahead of
time not to say those thoughts won't
change down the line that's happened to
me before too
anyways so the idea of this being some
version of the doctor that actually
predates William Hartnell so a doctor
from even before the character we know
is the first doctor I originally
dismissed this based purely on logistics
the fact that her TARDIS is a police box
the TARDIS would have no reason to a be
a police box and beed have a broken
chameleon circuit where it will be stuck
as a police box because the entire
background story is that the TARDIS had
the chameleon circuit which is supposed
to change it into something that will
blend in anywhere and landed in 1960s
and England it became a police box
community and circuit broke and it
stayed that way that's the entire
premise
by that explanation if she's prior to
her t'l it would have no reason to be a
police box
he hasn't landed in the 1960s yet now I
still hold to that but for the moment
let's set aside the log the logistical
argument and let's deal with why I think
this would be a bad idea
it's not because oh they just be making
so the doctor was always a woman and
they could try and claim that like I hey
I don't think so I'm B I don't care I
don't I have problems with this idea
that have nothing to do with what gender
color whatever the doctor is so for the
purposes of this video none of that's
getting brought up I don't care okay
okay so my big fears have to do with a
couple of things the first and foremost
is that retconning on this scale for
something that has been running this
long almost never goes well if you want
a good go-to you can make the comparison
to any number of comic book related
stories comic books very frequently pull
retcons history revisions and that's
even separate from the fact that they
reboot their continuity as all the dang
time or DC especially but it's always a
landmine to go back and say this thing
that you know about a character you love
isn't true has never been true and
belong gird the established in knowledge
has been in place that you're attempting
to subvert the more fraught the exercise
is gonna be because if you are flipping
the script on a character who's been
around a year
five years okay ten ooh
that's ballsy careful twenty thirty
fifty years and something you're gonna
massively change the things that are
going to alter the continuity and the
understanding of the character going all
the way back to dang near sixty years
ago just the number of pitfalls involved
with doing that and having a pre
Hartnell doctor inherently does that
regardless of the specifics of the
explanation exactly what is told to us
or given or confirmed or whatever if
they confirm that Ruth is from before
her t'l there are so many potholes for
this thing to hit so many pitfalls for
to just tumble into because when you go
that far back and start messing with
things there's a lot of dominoes you
changed this thing and it's got a
knock-on effect so whenever you are
altering or retconning something that
old there are likely going to be a lot
of unforeseen consequences that you
can't account for because it's not
reasonable for any one human being to
comb through literally sixty years worth
of history and calculate every single
bit of minutia that would be altered or
affected or would be changed by this and
either a account for it or be explained
why it's now not gonna be different
that's just unreasonable but that's why
you don't wreck on that fall back that
far back another thing that you know you
use as a comparison think about things
like alternate history fiction a lot of
alternate history fiction has divergent
points that say World War two or you
know the the Cold War
you don't get a lot of alternate history
fiction around say the Crusades around
Alexander the Great I mean you get
historical fiction but not like we're
saying that the world is split in this
way or when you're dealing with
alternate fiction if it's mono set where
the split happened it doesn't go that
far back it's like you know man in the
high castle we're in a world occupied by
the Nazis because we lost world war two
going back under a hundred years because
the further back you go the more changes
you have to account for and the less the
world as we know it could possibly be
the case because the knock-on effects
from a change that far back just keep
piling up so that's the first thing it's
just a fraud idea it's just a fraud
concept and the major thing with any
retcon that you need to ask yourself or
any creator needs to ask themselves what
are we losing what are we gaining
because you know retcon is a bit of a
dirty word I feel like in some fandoms
but there are many perfectly good
retcons it's just a question of whether
what we're losing is less significant
than what we gain and if what we're
losing is our entire understanding of
who the doctor is how his life has been
and the fact that he became the
character as we know him through his
journeys off of Gallifrey starting with
the first doctor well you're you're
losing a lot you're losing the entire
understanding of the life progression of
who this person was where they came from
and how they grew the way they did and
what are we gaining by having Ruth or
anyone be a pre Hartnell regeneration
now some people will bring up the
classic
brand of Morbius as a clue that they've
hinted at pre Hartnell regenerations
before and they did but it's also
backtrack since then because brand of
Morbius was a classic air show that
showed these faces that we'd never seen
before and it was implied that they were
pre hardened over generations of the
doctor but a it was only implied never
confirmed and B it was said by the
creators later like yeah that was kind
of what we were thinking later but then
later on we established the 13
regenerations rule and we figured that
it's not actually what it was was that
the original intention yes did they
stick with that plan no because it just
didn't make sense as the as Doctor Who
kept going that idea of regeneration
spree hurtle didn't make sense anymore
so they dropped it even though they
didn't plied it at the time I've
mentioned a number of things as
comparisons so far but I think the best
comparison that I can make if doctor who
attempts to do this attempts to give us
a regeneration pre Hartnell and say that
they were always there we just didn't
know would be to the spider and Clone
Saga because what Marvel tried to get
away with they introduced this
spider-man Club there was a spider-man
clone as part of a story from the 1970s
Orion that was it 90s they bring the
clone back shenanigans cool comic book
nonsense but then what happened in the
comics and what was supposed to be there
was the plan this was supposed to remain
the case was that it turned out the
clone Ben Riley was in fact the original
Peter Parker the whole time and the
Peter Parker that we'd been following
for the last 20-something odd years from
the point of when we first article in
the 70s was the clone the whole time
with Marvel having the intention that
Peter would go off and be with MJ and
have a home life and now we'd be
following Ben Riley
and that was a hard enough pill to
swallow it all that they were trying to
semi-retire Peter Parker and bring in
this other spider-man but it was
honestly insulting that they went I
don't know don't worry
that wasn't even actually Peter Parker
you didn't lose anything nothing changed
of course it did because that's still
the person we had all the investment in
and you just saying well it wasn't
really Peter so it's fine right no
that's not how attachment to characters
and concepts works I feel like I keep
circling back to the same thing you can
justify it narrowly in a narrative Li
all you want that doesn't mean it'll
land so the other thing about this is I
can't think of any scenario and what I
say I can't think of something that
doesn't mean it doesn't exist
it just means literary what say I can't
think of it maybe the people involved in
this are cleverer than me and can think
of it but I can't think of any scenario
that involves a regeneration of the
doctor pre Hartnell that does not also
involve some sort of memory wiping
because the doctor doesn't know who this
is so if you're going to put in that the
doctors had all these adventures and
regenerations and lives possibly a full
cycle of 13 who the heck knows prior to
when we knew her t'l and something
happened where it was all forgotten then
[Music]
what's the point it's a whole new set of
advent of adventures from a whole new
set of characters who we don't know and
whose existence didn't even impact the
character we do know because it's not
like we've learned more about how
they've been if the doctor doesn't
remember ever being these people then
effectively he never was
if his memory was completely wiped of
being the Ruth doctor or being whatever
prior to the first doctor and he's gone
however many thousands of years because
yes I go by that because when he was
stuck in the confession dial that that
was on a loop it was a weird temporal
thing I don't count that but fine you
want to count that five billions of
years old
and has had that entire life that entire
trajectory without the knowledge of
whatever happened before then it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter to who the
doctor is now and I so help me God if
they turn this into I don't even know
who I am yes you do you've been here
you've been living you know who you are
oh I so help me if there's a line like
that in the finale I'm gonna lose it and
that's my thing I I don't see what there
is to be gained from this if this is
indeed what happens and hopefully
fingers crossed it is not what will
actually happen I'm not gonna lie I am
nervous and we'll see
the problems at least my problems with
having regenerations that are older than
Hartnell oh there they go what do you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something on down in the
comments and let's talk about it usual
stuff like subscribe share those around
support me on patreon check out my
Instagram etc etc Twitter so on so forth
or don't you don't have to I'd
appreciate it but end of the day you are
the council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]